there's a school in in Utah
Westminster College Salt Lake City Utah
they are right now offering a course on
hardcore pornography
this is a private college not state
sponsored but it's a private college
offering a course on hardcore porn this
is gender 3000. so already you know the
course is in a gender studies Department
which means it should be abolished
because gender studies and all of these
sort of critical studies that cropped up
in recent decades to give stupid
students something that they can study
because they weren't able to keep up in
the real in the real academic
disciplines so you say okay we're going
to do gender and ethnicity and migration
studies and it's just it's just an
education in leftism and so as long as
you say the right political slogans you
can get a good grade and you can
graduate it was a it was a way to give
the the left an even stronger foothold
in education so the minute you see
gender studies you think okay
never mind this should get get rid of
this as long as we're fixing standards
here just abolish this whole department
turn it into a library or something in
any case the gender three studies course
is called porn and here's the
description hardcore pornography is as
American as apple pie and more popular
than Sunday Night Football our approach
to this billion dollar industry is as
both a cultural phenomenon that reflects
and reinforces sexual inequalities but
holds the potential to challenge sexual
and gender norms and as an art form that
requires serious contemplation we will
watch pornographic films together and
discuss the sexualization of race class
and gender as an experimental radical
art form
this is a very bad idea this is very
harmful to students education this
should not be permitted at any college
or university in the country this is
extremely obscene this appeals primarily
to the prurian interest and it is not
protected by free speech in in the
American tradition this class would have
no free speech protection
no first amendment protection
why
I it's not because
pornography is not a worthwhile
phenomenon to discuss it is it's a it's
a huge problem in America it's a major
political problem we don't really talk
about it enough
it's it's destroying the lives of
especially a lot of young men how many
times every week I get letters into my
mailbag lots of letters into my mailbox
saying I've been hooked on porn since I
was 10. it's ruined my life how do we
fix it so I I think the conversation is
really important to have I think it's
really important to study how
pornography was mainstreamed into
America how legal prohibitions against
it were overturned that's a really
interesting conversation
but that's not what this class does this
class involves sitting down with boys
and girls
and the teacher
watching this stuff
well that's very different
it'd be like taking a class on crystal
meth
in cocaine and hardcore narcotics
you could take a class on that in
chemistry for instance and talk about
these drugs and what they do and their
effects and you could even have a policy
discussion on whether or not they should
be legal or regulated that class would
be perfectly fine but the minute that
the class says okay and as part of your
final exam you're all going to do a
bunch of Crystal and tell me how it
feels you're all going to blow a bunch
of lines of coke smoke a pipe of crack
and tell me how it feels that's a very
different thing and that's what this
porn class is doing because the way that
you use a crack cocaine is by smoking it
the way that you use heroin is by
injecting it the way that you use
pornography is by watching it the very
Act of watching pornography is what
destroys that sort of academic
environment because when you watch porn
it's the same reason that you shouldn't
be be doing these kind of hardcore drugs
when you watch pornography you are not
appealing to your rational faculties
you're not appealing to your intellect
you actually you're not appealing to
your rational will you're losing control
of that because you're appealing to the
appetite
if you if you watch a lot of porn if you
do a lot of drugs if you drink too much
if you do things that are in the
Indulgence of your vices you are going
to lose your higher will it's gonna
you're gonna weaken your rational
faculties and that's not a very good
thing that's unfortunately that's what
our society has become I know that we
always talk about 1994 by George Orwell
as though that were the description of
the society we're living in there's
censorship there's an increasingly
totalitarian form of government yes sure
actually the way that the establishment
controls the American people is much
more like
Brave New World by Aldous Huxley then
1984 by George Orwell
Huxley who was Orwell's French teacher I
believe actually wrote a letter to him
to this effect and said you know George
it's a good book that you wrote but my
version of it is more accurate as to how
how political Elites actually gained
power
they don't do it by just smacking you
with a stick they don't do it by beating
you into submission they usually do it
by appealing to your desires by
appealing to your appetites and your
lusts they do it by by promoting drugs
by promoting promiscuous sex by
destroying the family but which which is
more
when you look at those two visions of a
dystopian society which seems more
correct the absolute rigid transparent
party program that has all of these very
strict rules that you've got to follow
or
or a society of licentiousness and
Hedonism that tells you if it feels good
do it obviously it's the latter that's
the way the society is decaying and
that's what that's not only is that a
function of the the really decayed
aspects of of popular culture that's now
what's literally being taught in a
universities the purpose of which is to
do the opposite the purpose of which is
to give you a liberal education and
teach you how to make sense of your
freedom I'm so glad you like that clip
now ring the bell subscribe get all the
notifications head on over also to Apple
podcast Spotify Stitch or Google Play
and type in the Michael Knowles show
subscribe leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]